squats I didn't come up with the
name this targets the quads in a big way
as well as strengthening the knees and
it's a significantly challenging
movement even if you're training only
with body weight it isolates the quads
really nicely so if you can build up to
squats they're going to give you
both Aesthetics and a better running
speed and jump height perfect for
functional training that said they're
also very tough on the knees so don't do
these if you have existing issues
instead find an easier regression that
easier regression is the Hindu squat
when you simply squat on your toes you
can do this with a partial range of
motion too if it's too difficult I'm
doing squats with my hands near
the sofa this is just to support me as I
get closer to the ground giving me the
stability I want in order to be able to
build some strength and hypertrophy
remember stability is necessary for
making strength gains I said if you're
more interested in the balance gains you
can try and ignore the support as much
as possible it becomes quite a cool
party trick once you can do it without
focus on driving your knees forwards
towards the ground